when you're looking out for a platform
usually
it's just water everywhere which makes
you feel really really tiny jumping into
this
giant ocean
i'm rachelle simpson
and i'm a world champion cliff driver
it's very similar to olympic diving the
only difference is at the end we're
going to land on our feet
as i climb up on the platform you hear
the wind blowing in your ears
sometimes there's seagulls zooming
around my head
i hear the announcer call my name
it's kind of like i'm going into this
hallway and the sound slowly cutting out
because that's when i'm going into focus
that's when i set my feet and then my
arms go up
i count to three
and go
your body's on autopilot and your brain
is just sitting back watching front
somersault full twist second somersault
right position half twist
when you hit the water at first you
don't notice anything and then it starts
all coming back you create bubbles
underneath the surface and you feel
those bubbles pushing you back up to the
surface quite a cool feeling actually
when you come up take a breath of air
and the rush of adrenaline just like
you've been holding it off
and not even breathing until you hit
that water
each time i enter the water it's another
successful moment of convincing my brain
to do something i'm scared of but each
time i get a sense of empowerment when i
overcome it
i love it